hello I'm gay I'm done we are the slow
mo guys and today we're not in my back
garden where it's nice and bright we're
in my dark dingy garage where we keep
our props so news your press the reason
for that is because we've had a lot of
requests to film an iris constricting
when it comes into a lot of light very
suddenly you can't do that outside and
we're gonna film this on a macro lens a
thousand frames a second usually the
macro lenses we've used their slightly
bulky and I think I'd actually struggled
to get at your eyeball because of your
big old eyebrow in the amber tal brow
and eye socket so we're using this Laur
macro lens which is a very odd shape but
it took the lens cap off it also has LED
lighting and I think with this I'll
actually be able to get right up against
your ball my eyeball oh as long as you
know poke my eye out
Nakia something the widest aperture on
this lens is an f-14 which is actually
gonna make it very dark on my shooting
out a thousand frames a second so it's
very good that it's got a light on the
end of it stick it on the camera here
it's actually longer than the camera
let's tell you that well we could either
film your eye or I could give you some
sort of medical examination know which
one I prefer
so when set close to infinity looks like
just a normal lens except you can go
much much much closer
now in a bit right there you go down
slightly perfect you're right in the
middle that God even just my breathing
is like rock and real all over the place
don't bash your eyeball oh you can see
you feel relaxed I mean honestly this is
gonna be one of the easier videos for me
technically to do cuz all I have to do
is sit in a chair really still at the
same time it's not relaxing because I'm
gonna have a huge lens shoved in my
eyeball and a bunch of bright lights
turned on immediately yeah I'll be no
big movements anymore okay plug in the
lens power oh my god that's bright
the thing is me like my heart beating is
moving my eye off I'm gonna set the
frame rate back to a thousand and then
turn the lights off in here for a bit
whoa that is talk you know I've got like
floaties now Louise yeah we love a move
already
yeah oh god I can't lie I've got
absolutely donut in my eye now like all
I can see is a huge fat pink and blue
donut oh it's completely blue now it's
just got this blue ring in my vision oh
it's really weird did I think it was it
alright look at it I don't think I've
ever seen an eye so open that close
oh that's me I'm weird my stomach's
starting revenue oh there you go that's
closer
see that yeah
look at the moisture on my eyeball
that is
mental so the focus has changed slightly
I decided you know maybe 10 the like it
was a little less bright I could do it
less Brian I can maybe half the
framerate hmm there 500 yeah I think
that might be a good idea the thing is
my heart beats like moving me you making
me laugh is making me like move a bunch
oh this is an amazing me if you can over
there we're on the closest I can be 100
G good Oh
flippin Eck right this is what's
happening okay first of all there's like
I can hold it there for ages for a start
there's immediately like just a flash of
just pure brightness yeah and then it
slowly turns into a doughnut like the
doughnut is originally like this and
then it becomes like a doughnut with a
bigger hole in the middle because my
eyes constricting and then less of it
and I can see more detail of the light
if you know I mean
Wow I'm so weird
don't move so there's actually a small
delay I wonder we could probably count
that delayed by the friends and you see
all these craters yeah they're actually
really soft and fibrous like when your
eye is completely dilated ah they change
shape those holes on the outside of my
eye was so much fatter and bigger now
they're like tall ovals yeah weird it
like drags the entire pattern and you
can actually see them layers but you can
very clearly here see wise on top and
what is underneath of your iris so weird
and like my iris isn't perfectly
circular see there's like little bits on
the outside that like coming around oh
it's true it's crazy to think that every
single thing you have ever seen it was
through that hole it's the way behalf of
it this is the closer of them this is
the closest to the window to the soul
you could possibly be you're basically
trying to look into my soul here I
reckon I can do this one thing where I
like move my iris really like quickly
from side to side oh you like to shake
your eyes yeah like shake my ball
slightly yeah like that oh you went like
cross-eyed I can't do it quite as big as
that but I think cause we're so close
you should be able to see a bit of shake
egde and when I was filming my eye and I
was moving my around I could see this or
because the iris is a muscle and is
liquid it was like jostling so wonder if
when your eye vibrates would be like
like slushie almost weird yeah we'll
find out all right was it yeah oh yeah
it's doing it you're there like oh I'm
like salsa dancing what I I didn't no
idea was that liquidy oh my god do you
see that so those areas of your eye
whether it's kind of almost like craters
yeah loose I didn't know that they're
like they almost have their own eyelids
they do look how that the fibers are
like closing in
like moving about do you see that looks
like just sort of like a fat but jigglin
everything I so gelatinous it's like
jelly it's almost like a weave like it's
all like each one is string I think
that's what it is that's the best way to
describe it it's not good jiggles a
spaghetti
looks like overcooked spaghetti moving
around well that was some graphic
looking for it one donut that's about
right yeah I'll tell you what though I
don't think I can ever in the future use
iris recognition software because
everyone has the perfect image of my
eyeball yeah exactly and iris can does
not work you've got the least secure
iris now yeah
and I've already felt my eye so we're
both toast oh well hopefully you enjoyed
that video or you were grossed out by it
I feel like either one is a victory for
us please feel free to subscribe to the
slow mo guys and a check back you know a
little bit for the next video
well hopefully Dan I'll be able to see
you again your life's in my hands now
got a drive home with you in the car
another roundabout